[Musik]
ok also lasst uns wirklich jetzt einfach
nur noch geisteskrank dom sind wir nicht
mit einer leute unsere eltern wussten es
schon lange unsere generation ist handy
süchtig gut ist aber das problem beim
namen genannt stellt sich die frage was
kann man machen um mit der eigenen handy
sucht um zu gehen falls ihr zuhause da
sitzt und sich denkt sebastian ich weiß
nicht mehr weiter ich weiß nicht was
dagegen machen soll
keine sorge eine gewisse ratgebersendung
von der ihr vielleicht schon mal gehört
hab namens hilf mir hat genau zu diesem
thema einen beitrag veröffentlicht und
den schauen uns jetzt an
ach ja das video heißt let me take xlv
ich bin süchtig nach sex also es wird
schon mal relativ schmerzhaft so viel
dass man schon die frage ist nur noch
wie schmerzhaft genau die beschreibung
verrät uns dass der name von dem mädchen
was wir hier sehen
jesse ist und jesse ist diejenige die
süchtig nach sex ist hier sehen wir
jetzt ihren arbeitsplatz also die
arbeitet in der arztpraxis und jetzt
haben wir ganz grundlegend zu dieser
folge
wie kann man überhaupt süchtig nach sell
fies sein
wie kann man süchtig nach fotos von sich
selbst sein okay der zweite blick in die
beschreibung sagt uns dass jesse
scheinbar irgendwie stress mit ihrem
vater hat zu hause hat eine neue
freundin und b sie also seine tochter
deswegen jetzt schmeißen problem ist die
verdient in der arztpraxis nicht so viel
dass sie sich jetzt ohne weiteres eine
eigene wohnung holen kann
die lösung dafür ist süchtig nach
service zu werden und als influenza ihr
geld zu verdienen
ja vielleicht nicht hier wird aber mit
der idee die ich habe und die wärme mit
instagram mit diesen fotos
ok also wir sehen das schon mal leute
diese frau die hat einen guten geschäfts
planen business plan wie man auf
englisch sagt der sieht konkret so aus
ich werde mein geld verdienen mit
instagram mit den ganzen voll aus also
man merkt jetzt schon ganz genau
gedanken gemacht was wir davor hat und
wird sicherlich auch erfolg damit haben
ganz ehrlich leute das von obmann ist
ein junge jesse ist ein junger mensch
mit träumen mit konkreten plänen für
übertragungsraten schon gehört mit
instagram mit die ganze follows und ihre
kollegin glaubt einfach nicht an sie
okay also sie wartet nur noch darauf
dass sie große rauskommt hat sich schon
irgendwas dafür gemacht groß
rauszukommen
ich glaube so weit noch nicht aber sie
wartet darauf dass die groß rauskommt es
kann ja passieren manchmal kommt man
auch groß raus ohne einen finger dafür
zu gründen
[Musik]
das darf doch da nicht so entstehen
leute ganz ehrlich diese die frau ist
nicht aufzuhalten
die hatten plan die wird mit die ganze
follower groß raus kommt vielleicht
vielleicht macht sie irgendwann auch mal
was dafür gehen vielleicht postet sie
auch irgendwann bild aber schild erst
mal okay vielleicht geht sie auch ohne
dass tatsächlich auch der erste schritt
da von den normalen job zu kündigen und
vollzeit in fenster zu werden man sollte
auf jeden fall immer sein handy
vergessen weil wenn man sein handy dabei
hat könnte man ja in die situation
kommen fotos zu machen
aber man will ja eigentlich auch ohne
irgendwas zu machen groß rauskommen also
ganz wichtig auf keinen falls handy
mitnehmen
das wären alter sie will erfolgreiche
ins marien werden und schaltet einfach
schon so bei der alle einfachsten sache
okay du brauchst nicht viel über auf
insulin erfolgreich zu werden so
reinfall techniker du brauchst einfach
nur ein handy und dass das hat dann
leider ihr vater
[Musik]
gut ja sie ist hier am arbeitsplatz an
der rezeption von der arztpraxis wo sie
arbeitet reißt sich natürlich jetzt mal
erst mal komplett die klamotten vom leib
und macht dann 111 abstoßen
die die frau kommt doch überhaupt nicht
lange die ist an ihrem arbeitsplatz hat
so die bluse gefühlt komplett
aufgerissen und so kleine rote okay also
der der wahnsinn im leben von unserer
lieben safer süchtigen jesse geht weiter
jetzt sitzt sie am arbeitsplatz in der
praxis und bearbeitet ihre am handy auch
in der praxis gemachten bilder ganz
ehrlich warum die doch nicht gefeuert
wurde kann ich nicht sagen aber
vielleicht liegt sache das einfach auch
kein patient in der praxis ist also ist
sogar bisher keinen einzigen cent
gesehen
die praxis scheint gut zu laufen jetzt
bin ich schockiert
tatsächlich die die erste patientin ist
in die praxis gekommen
die sessel juckt selber nicht bearbeitet
einfach eiskalt die bild weiter bürger
die frau die ist nicht mehr zu retten
ziemlich die einzige die auf irgendwas
wartet doch
die ist die einzige patientin in dieser
praxis sie ist wirklich die einzige das
ist niemals leute dieser mensch macht
sich sorgen
okay die macht den ganzen tag schon nur
scheiße gelabert chance die macht
scheiße sein sich was sie bisher gemacht
hat in diesem arbeitstag ist von sich
selbst ein bild zu machen bei dem sie
ihren ausschnitt zeigt okay dann
bearbeitet sie das bild auf ihrem laptop
und dann kommt die einzige patientin
wahrscheinlich die einzigen seit jahren
in die praxis rhein und die wird einfach
die wir einfach nicht bedient ich hab
keinen bock mehr auf dem betrieb wenn
sie hier unfähig sind ihren job zu
machen haben sie hier das problem und
nicht ich okay ganz ehrlich wie soll man
bei dieser frau nicht aggressiv werden
wie von ihrer seite aus nicht gerade
freundlich nee nee also ganz ehrlich ich
finde das kann man nicht sagen
die patientin hat sich auf jeden fall
falsch verhalten werte natürlich erstmal
auf die knie fallen müssen und um
erlaubnis bitten müssen mit der
instagram berühmten jesse zu sprechen
[Musik]
okay das ist natürlich jetzt auch
vernünftig auf jeden fall also der
nächste schritt auf dem weg zur
erfolgreichen entwicklung ist natürlich
ein wissens alle leute ein safety auf
einem kran zu machen
ganz ehrlich jeder weiß also kräne sind
ein sehr beliebtes thema auf instagram
kriegt auch mit die meisten likes
deutlich beliebter ist zum beispiel
hundebabys oder so was wir ja keiner
sehen
kräne das ist es
[Musik]
okay das ist wirklich jetzt einfach nur
noch geisteskrank dumm dieses mädchen
ist jetzt mit fucking stiefel mit
absätzen apple gerade eben gesehen auf
einen kran drauf geklettert um da sich
auszuziehen und 111 ii zu machen also
viel behinderter kann man in seinem kopf
wirklich nicht sein
ohne wird sollte ich dabei der war die
die schaukel in ihrer kindheit ein
bisschen zu nah an der wand aufgestellt
also so dumm kann eigentlich kann
eigentlich ein mensch nicht okay also
jetzt läuft sie mit ihrer kollegin
sharon wir durch die stadt ist
höchstwahrscheinlich auf der suche nach
dem nächsten spot für das perfekte
instagram foto-app ministerrat eben
schon im hintergrund so dieser
polizeiwagen aufgefallen
ich vermute war das steht da nicht aus
zufall okay okay ist hatte ich dann
gedauert bis jazz genialer kopf mit der
idee um die ecke kam dass sie sich mal
auf dieses polizeiauto setzen sollte für
instagram ja nicht unbedingt die klügste
entscheidung
[Musik]
diese frau ist doch so lost alter also
jetzt ist sie allen ernstes auf das
polizeiauto drauf geklettert das ist
natürlich auch wieder ein sehr schlauer
geschäfts muss man sagen also das ist
schon eine geschäftsfrau die auf jeden
fall mit denkt weil nach kränen und
halbnackten service auf kränen ist die
zweitbeliebteste kategorie auf instagram
natürlich bilder auf der motorhaube von
polizeiautos okay der polizist kam jetzt
mit pizzakarton nicht ganz kurz und hirn
kurzschluss schirmer vor so die laufende
wechselfrist lustig und der polizist
rastet einfach so aus zieht seine waffe
so scheiß instagram und weil er die
einfach so ab
[Musik]
okay ganz ehrlich leute das war's jetzt
komplett wirklich jetzt sitzt sie auf
einer fucking schaute sie sitzt auf
einer schaukel und macht auf einer
schaukel ins lvr wer will so etwas sehen
natürlich sollte man muss sagen wir da
sehr wertvolle ratgeber folge definitiv
die hilft mir herausgehauen hat der
beste rat für leute die sehr viel
süchtig sind ist seit einfach nicht
geistig behindert und seid einfach
nichts helfe süchtig exakt so weit der
pro tipp von mir leute ich hab euch hier
noch einen für euch persönlich
vorgeschlagenes video verlinkt das war
so weit von mir
bis zum nächsten mal